Debbie Rowe gets candid about her battle
with breast cancer you don't have a
choice
Michael Jackson's ex-wife sat down with
et where she opened up about the fight
of her life you're tough you've dealt
with a lot of tough things in your life
yes and you handled them so I can
imagine what it was like for a doctor
facing down with you it was like well I
thought it was open for negotiation
and it was like no there is no
negotiation we're not buying a car we're
going for a Cure and this is what we're
doing and I said what if we just do
radiation no what did we do just the
lumpectomy no I got a lot of knows from
my doctors what those are knows you
appreciate completely absolutely and my
oncologist said we're going for a cure
we're not going for a band-aid we're not
going for a fit we're going for a cure
how hard has it been dealing with the
side effects brutal brutal chemo does
its best to make you lose your
femininity you lose your hair you lose
your eyelashes you lose your eyebrows
Debbie also tells et how cancer has
brought her closer to her daughter Paris
Jackson what does it mean to you that
Paris is she's beautiful she's my rock
she's amazing
she's been with me the whole time tune
in to ET tonight to find out how Debbie
thinks Michael Jackson would react to
her cancer battle and the reveal of her
hair loss for the first time on TV
you